automne 2013 je découvre le val de gerbe
unique et sa particularité un paysage
rural transformé par une industrie
métallurgique intense vieille de
plusieurs siècles usine route et un
système de canaux permettant le
transport des marchandises dessine le
val
au milieu du 19e siècle l'industrie du
fer se déplace vers la lorraine germigny
sur le déclin mais une seconde industrie
voit le jour la fabrication de la chaux
nous retrouvons sylvie notre guide sur
le site de chabrol ancienne usine de
shoah bef le paysage semble bucolique
mais au 19e cet endroit précis vous avez
d'abord une foule de personnes qui est
en train de travailler énormément de
bruit puisque on peut concasser les
pierres calcaires pour fabriquer la
chaux et là on est au niveau des
gueulards donc des fours dans lesquels
on va faire passer la chaux qui va cuire
entre 900 et 1000 de son degré dont vous
avez la chaleur la poussière absolument
aucun arbre tout commence ici sous cela
qu une ancienne mine de calcaire à ciel
ouvert elle alimente l usine de baisse
la chaux se fabrique en calcinant le
calcaire dans d'immenses foules puis en
l'arrosant d'une pluie fine
la chose se désagrège en poussière c'est
un show fournier qui s'occupe des fours
et la première les caps et d'allumer le
feu ça dure à peu près cinq jours et ça
va être valable pour le show fournier
pendant à peu près dix mois en continu
il faut pas que le four c'était la
deuxième chose c'est qu'on va embraser
la première couche de charbon qui
embrase les pierres calcaires qui sont
au dessus qui vont embraser l'autre
couche de charbon qui est encore au
dessus on a un feuilleté comme ça
jusqu'en haut à peu près sept huit
lettres de defour
fin 19ème siècle le val de germiny
possède 25 usines soit plus de 100 floor
1800 ouvriers y travaillent jour et nuit
les conditions de travail sont dures
la santé précaire devant une show
agressif pour la peau et les voies
respiratoires
dès 1897 les ouvriers entrent dans des
actions revendicatives
sylvie où il y a un travail à la
reconnaissance patrimoniale du site
williams dont le père a travaillé ici
vient d'éditer un livre sur la mémoire
du val la création à chaud a
complètement modifié le paysage ont déjà
le village des villages environnants il
était déjà blanchi dans la poussière qui
à l'époque de la chaux la production ici
du baça de bêtes en 1926 et représentait
14% de la production française perd
qu'une importance du bassin le niveau
fabrication de la chaux et le ciment
était quand même le deuxième en france
après le juge yves duteil dans l'ardèche
des années 1900 verront naître des
améliorations techniques les fours
seront alimentés par des wagonnets les
bancs de refroidissement couvert la
rentabilité au maximum jusqu'à l'arrivée
d'un concurrent
le ciment à partir du moment où le
ciment devient est utilisé en béton armé
on peut réaliser des bâtiments entiers à
ce moment là la chaux ne peut être
concurrentiel et c'est comme ça que
m'est en 1934 vizille ferme
bref depuis 20 ans porte un projet de
réhabilitation du site
expositions concerts marché tout est bon
pour faire du lien entre mémoire et
présent plus largement le val de germiny
reconnu par la route européennes du
patrimoine industriel s'inscrit comme un
paysage d'exception